talk to me about your uh your just I
feel like every Chris Brown album you
somehow have your fingerprints on in
some capacity yeah
um how did you guys first link up and
just talk about why he trusts you so
much yeah so uh she's also a great
writer he is he is that's why I you know
I definitely don't take it lightly
um just that you know that trust uh the
first song we did was called Champion it
was for a London artist named chipmunk
Harmony called me in for the session I
wrote The Hook and he just re-cut the
hook and was like yo whoever did that
whoever that was singing I want them to
work on my next album so he brought the
whole team with Harmony and myself and
Courtney and and we all went to the man
straight in with Chris Brown you know
what I mean I was I was actually in
London working
um and had to get a call to come back
the next day literally like I landed had
to go right back I didn't do no work and
we got in with him and wrote all the
songs on on Fame oh my love uh Champion
ended up going on there say it with me
and did not join one of his first White
Grammy was Fame
the first album after kind of the whole
shindig that went yeah yeah the graffiti
kind of art yeah so that was like kind
of his comeback that was the one and it
got a Grammy so it's like we was
involved in such a pivotal moment I felt
like uh it was like let's keep doing it
yeah and then you did find China right
yeah Fine China is such a great record
man that's that's my favorite one though
as I said when you write a song like
Fine China are you with him or do you
send it to him and if you send it to him
or you're kind of hoping he doesn't want
it so you keep it for yourself nah I'm
with him okay hey I'm with him uh any of
the songs that are like the big ones
like New Flame and love more it was cool
it was all there yeah but when I'm by my
myself a lot of them songs nobody I
don't be playing them for nobody you
know for one it's like I'm gonna keep
this and I can do whatever I want with
it and it's gonna benefit me more
low-key to have ownership of the song as
opposed to
um if I go to a session and I'm with
somebody else that's their studio time
they pay for that that's most likely
they beat so I never really be too
connected I'm always like pouring all my
energy into the moment was Usher in the
session for New Flame Usher was not that
she was not he's on that song yeah he's
on that song
um who else somebody else someone else
is singing song yeah I feel like there's
a rapper no it wasn't Rick Ross
somebody's on that side it might just be
him and Russia I don't know it might be
I feel like I'm missing a rapper you're
a [__] no you wouldn't know baby
all alone
my guy over there big Yeet fan yeah Have
you listened to Yeet I just seen his
logo he's popping as [__] I just seen it
pop up on the page I don't get it it's
not for me to get the name hey it's so
many things that come out now I'm like
wow it's so many different names of new
people and artists and it's just like I
just respect it because I remember when
it was like who's this Eric Bellinger
guy yeah what do you feel like uh for
because I do feel like there has been a
dope Resurgence in like aren't beginning
respect again in terms of like you know
traditional r b coming back like you
know guys like yourself you got a girl
like LMA yeah go on and on and on
there's so much dope r b in the world
right now
um but you've been pushing through the
whole wave yeah and I feel like your
first project comes out in 2010
which I refer to as the dark era yeah
because that's when like
EDM got introduced and it was all of
these r b artists that is when it
happened so there was like this was like
the Lady Gaga and I'm the only one still
waving away yeah and so like you're
still putting out traditional r b I
think around that time yeah August was
starting to come out with his mixtape
yeah August Adrian Marcel had a dope
mixtape yeah
Ty dollars
but yeah like for you like you've been
through so many eras of r b like uh yeah
do you recall when it like what was it
like to not be cool to be the r b guy
um
because you think Neo's biggest songs
are the yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you
know what I mean more on the floor
joints you know it was it was not only
did
the r b not become as popular
but I was also I was also I was also
singing
at a time
out and was married too you know what I
mean so like I
that wasn't the cool like everybody
wasn't booed up that wasn't like Bagels
like we were he married and making r b
music yeah I was not like right you feel
me and but I I knew like yo also shout
out to Miguel who's holding that flag
too at that time he was yes he was for
sure and I wasn't I wasn't aiming to
also married at the time ish maybe with
this girl ish yeah we've been going big
time the jump this is the big boy when
you really in there yeah and you in
there you walk down that aisle yeah it
is different it hits different it is
different for sure the commitment was
like I was dedicated we've ride we've we
vibed it out and she held me up when you
once you got that woman that queen that
make you feel like you got it you good
so that sustained me and my fans really
just let me know like yo thank you for
being the only one that we can listen to
when it comes to positive influence in
relationships when it thinks of just
like r b like I want to love on my girl
as opposed to everything being the
opposite you know so me just giving
people another option
it became the standard and it became the
new wave after people got tired of
disrespecting and being disrespected
yeah there was also like like you're
saying there was the Super toxic r b
[__] where it was like Jesus Christ
it was really crazy some of the [__]
that was a girlfriend's girlfriend oh my
God it was going crazy shout out to Trey
Songz yeah the most toxic r b of all
time this is still Girl Gotta give it to
him Jesus Christ it's like where'd the
love go God damn it yeah it was gone
it's gone I was just like yo I'm here
and I don't do it for Applause I do it
for a cause you know what I'm saying I
love that man